we saw this story I thought it was a
great story and then I found out the
story behind the story and it became
even better the Pirates relievers Steven
brawled he sang the national anthem last
night let me give you a taste of that
then we'll bring in Steven and he'll
tell you how this came about that he was
gonna be at home plate to sing the
star-spangled banner once he got there
then I I knew he was he was in the clear
because there's there's a couple spots
in the anthem and singers will tell you
that where you got to get there and
that's when I think Steven was he threw
a fastball right there and he's kind
enough to join us Steven how are you
today what what are the reviews that you
got from your anthem listening little
high two waiters is that the first time
you've heard out back no I I listen to
it like afterwards home and it was it's
interesting hearing it you know I'm sure
you guys understand but it's weird
hearing it again and me knowing myself
and knowing when I was singing and I was
like that I was kind of a little weird
but you know but ya know it was it was
very once you go and the Rockets red
glare like that that can be death though
like you almost had were you thinking
subconsciously I call boy here it comes
and I got to get to a certain point
absolutely yeah I think that's probably
actually the most underrated part of the
anthem because everybody thinks about
like the free you know
but the Rockets red glare sits right up
there so I I was I was a little worried
I I knew it was coming up so you know it
worked out for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]